Это степь номер 4 - Митинг.
Это корректор.
Что мы должны создать?
Мы должны создать митинг.
Как мы уже сделали это в предыдущем степи.
Это работает perfect.
Следующий момент - Счеду митинг.
Счеду митинг.
Колендар.
Когда я нажму "Скеду митинг" - "Add to calendar",
У меня Google Calendar opens.
Я имею ввидение с Евгенией.
Я имею ввидение.
Я имею ввидение ввидения.
Я использую линию ввидение.
Ввидение.
Ввидение ввидения.
Я вижу все степи.
Конфигуру на микрофон и камера.
Я skipped.
Ввидение.
Не забывайте пригласить ваших друзей.
Увидение.
Ввидение ввидения.
Я отправлю ссылку на Оскар.
Субтитры делал DimaTorzok
И это не работает, это работает от третий раз или с большим делом с этим.
Придравление сетапа.
А, да, мы уже сделали эту часть, это работает хорошо.
Митинг менеджмент.
Поехали обратно на митинг.
Самый?
Да, самый.
Следующий этап является быть партиспантом.
Видео на ней.
Да, я вижу кнопку.
Подписывайтесь на видео.
Подписывайтесь на Оскар.
Я не знаю, что это было.
40 минут, для basic tariff, мы не нужно сидеть 40 минут для этого, я думаю, что это было бы не идея.
Я создал новую митинг-линк, это занимается около 5 секунд, когда я rejoиню на менеджмент, я смотрю на менеджмент,
я смотрю на менеджмент, я смотрю на менеджмент, я смотрю на менеджмент, я смотрю на менеджмент,
и я смотрю на менеджмент, я смотрю на менеджмент, я смотрю на менеджмент, я смотрю на менеджмент,
я смотрю на менеджмент, я смотрю на менеджмент, я смотрю на менеджмент.
Таааааааааааааа